the UN says an estimated 70,000 people
in northern Syria have been forced to
flee because of turkeys assault on us
back Kurdish forces Turkish warplanes
and artillery blasted targets across the
Syrian border overnight on this a third
day of the offensive Charlie d'Agata
filed this report from inside Syria well
this is the city of Qamishli in northern
Syria it's a very important city for the
Kurdish population it sort of serves as
their administrative center but we're
only about a mile and a half from the
Turkish border that means that it's
vulnerable to airstrikes artillery and
even mortars and that's exactly what
happened here
a couple of nights ago it came under a
mortar attack three mortars slammed into
this neighborhood killing one person on
the spot two more people were injured in
there now fighting for their lives in
the hospital so it's this kind of random
violence in these neighborhoods that has
sparked a mass exodus of Kamisha we saw
that for ourselves last night a
bottleneck on the main road leading
south away from these Turkish air
strikes and mortar attacks like this
families that didn't want to take a
chance with their young children of
attacks like this now the Turkish
government has defended this military
operation saying that they're clearing
this area of terrorists but more and
more it's starting to look more like a
campaign of ethnic cleansing forcing
local area Kurdish population away from
the cities and villages and then instead
putting in place many Syrian Arabs who
sought refuge in Turkey people that
don't come from this region and that has
now become a point of discussion not
only among the local population here but
in the international community for CBS
this morning Charlie d'Agata and kameez
Lee northern Syria